-Finally, it is time to take
a look at the stories
making headlines today
and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons,"
here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Pros and cons ♪
♪ And pros and cons and pros ♪
[ Applause ]
-Tonight, we'll be taking a look
at the pros and cons
of legalizing weed
in New Jersey.
That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
As of last week,
people in New Jersey
can now buy
recreational marijuana.
So let's take a look
at the pros and cons
of legalizing weed
in New Jersey.
And here we go.
Pro...
[ Laughter ]
Con...
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Imitating New Jersey accent ]
What was I supposed to
remember 'bout?
[ Applause ]
Pro...
Con...
There you go, that's --
[ Applause ]
Pro...
Con -- to this...
There you go, it's --
[ Applause ]
Pro...
Con...
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cymbal crashes ]
[ Laughter, applause ]
Pro...
Con...
That's a -- yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Pro...
Con...
[ Applause ]
Pro...
Con...
Hey!
[ Laughter ]
Whoa.
[ Drumbeats ]
Pro...
Con...
[ Laughter, applause ]
And finally, pro...
Con...
That's the pros and cons,
everybody.